[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
donnerstag die vom sport hat sven voss
auch von mir einen schönen guten abend
wir haben unter anderem diese themen für
sie
möglicher anschlag auf synagoge
verhindert nach einem großeinsatz am
höchsten jüdischen feiertag nimmt die
polizei in hagen vier männer fest
einigung im tarifstreit bei der bahn die
lokführergewerkschaft gdl spricht von
einem guten kompromiss weitere streiks
sind vom tisch und
vw-manager auf der anklagebank sechs
jahre nachdem diesel skandal hat der
erste strafprozess gegen ehemalige
führungskräfte begonnen
eine synagoge als anschlagsziel und das
am höchsten jüdischen feiertag jom
kippur das erinnert an die ereignisse
von halle vor zwei jahren jetzt hat die
polizei einen entsprechenden plan
möglicherweise gerade noch verhindern
können in hagen nahmen die beamten einen
16 jährigen syrer vorläufig fest
die dortige synagoge hatten sie schon
gestern abend großräumig um stellt weil
so hieß es heute klare hinweise auf
tatzeit tatort und täter vorgelegen
hätten thaddäus parade
spezialeinheiten der polizei
überraschten am frühen morgen einen der
vier tatverdächtigen in seiner wohnung
polizeiliche ermittlungen hatten zur
spur der männer geführt die offenbar
einen sprengstoffanschlag auf die
hagener synagoge geplant hatten sonntag
fertig ding ist zu sagen dass wir zum
einen über einen 16 jährigen hagener
sprechen syrische staatsangehörigkeit
und weitere drei tatverdächtige die in
der wohnung des 16 jährigen angetroffen
und festgenommen wurden deutsche
sicherheitsbehörden waren durch einen
ausländischen geheimdienst gewarnt
worden zuvor haben wir einen sehr ernst
zu nehmenden und konkreten hinweis
erhalten dass es während des jom kippur
festes zu einem anschluss auf die
synagoge kommen könnte der hinweis ließ
rückschlüsse auf eine islamistisch
motivierte bedrohungslage zu die
anteilnahme in allen politischen lagern
ist groß betroffen zeigte sich nicht nur
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer auch
die bundesjustizministerin zitat es ist
unerträglich dass jüdinnen und juden
erneut einer so schrecklichen
bedrohungslage ausgesetzt sind und den
beginn ihres höchsten festes jom kippur
nicht friedlich gemeinsam feiern konnten
wegen yom kippur haben sich heute
jüdische gemeinden zum vorfall in hagen
nicht geäußert
mittlerweile hat die
generalstaatsanwaltschaft düsseldorf
ermittlungen gegen die jungen männer
aufgenommen wegen verdachts der
vorbereitung einer staatsgefährdenden
gewalttat
und inzwischen teilte die
generalstaatsanwaltschaft düsseldorf mit
dass ein tatverdacht bislang nur gegen
einen der vier vorläufig festgenommenen
besteht
millionen bahnkunden können aufatmen die
zeit der streiks ist erst mal vorbei die
gewerkschaft deutscher lokführer gdl und
das management der bahn haben sich
überraschend geeinigt als vermittler
helfen zwei ministerpräsidenten mit drei
großen streiks hatte die gdl weite teile
des zugverkehrs lahmgelegt hans jörn
biel hat die details mit ihnen kam die
lösung die ministerpräsidenten von
niedersachsen und schleswig holstein
stephan weil und daniel günther hatten
offenbar schon seit tagen unter striktem
stillschweigen im festgefahrenen
tarifstreit zwischen gdl und bahn
vermittelt wir können glaube ich beide
feststellen dass sich die vergangenen
zehn tage in denen wir mehrere
verhandlungen auch führen durften hier
in berlin definitiv gelohnt haben wobei
das keine schlichtung gewesen ist das
war ja wie soll man sagen moderation
mitwirkung an gesprächen irgendetwas
dazwischen aber wenn es sein beitrag
geleistet hat dann ist es ja gut jetzt
also die einigung 3,3 prozent
gehaltserhöhung wird es geben davon 1,5
prozent noch in diesem jahr und 2 corona
prämien von bis zu 600 euro erstmals
geht ein gdl tarifvertrag auch in
werkstätten und teilen der verwaltung
das war der lokführergewerkschaft
besonders wichtig es ging um grundgesetz
artikel 9 absatz 3 und die frage ob wir
tarifverträge für alle unsere mitglieder
abschließen können oder nicht wir haben
auch hier einen kompromiss gemacht so
soll der abschluss nicht wie von der gdl
gefordert im bereich infrastruktur
gelten hier hat die
konkurrenzgewerkschaft evg bereits einen
tarifvertrag weil der geringere entgelte
vorsieht will die bahn um den
betriebsfrieden zu wahren den gdl tarif
jetzt auch der evg anbieten für den
gleichen zeitraum die lange laufzeit von
32 monaten also bis ende oktober 2023
gibt uns notwendige planungssicherheit
das ist wichtig für eine unternehmen
mitte deutsche bahn seit anfang august
hatte die lokführergewerkschaft den
schienenverkehr insgesamt dreimal
bestreikt zuletzt standen die züge für
mehr als fünf tage still
es ist einer der größten
wirtschaftsskandale der deutschen
geschichte vw hatte millionen diesel
fahrzeuge illegal manipuliert die
wiedergutmachung kostete den konzern
bereits milliarden
das landgericht braunschweig soll jetzt
klären wer dafür die strafrechtliche
verantwortung trägt vor gericht stehen
vier ehemalige führungskräfte ex
konzernchef winterkorn ist aus
gesundheitlichen gründen noch nicht
dabei peter kunz die diese krise
wirtschaftlich möchte volkswagen sie
gern vergessen 32 milliarden euro
schaden längst weggesteckt die
strafrechtliche aufarbeitung aber hinkte
bisher hinterher sechs jahre
ermittlungen zweimal prozessbeginn
verschoben ein früherer chef manager und
drei ehemals leitende angestellte müssen
sich jetzt dafür verantworten dass
volkswagen jahrelang dreckige motoren
als sauber verkauft hat der vorwurf
lautet auf banden- und gewerbsmäßigen
betrugs steuerhinterziehung und
strafbare werbung mit wissen von ex
vorstand heinz jakob neußer sollen
diesel fahrzeuge mit einer illegalen
abschalt vorrichtung ausgestattet worden
sein die den schadstoffausstoß auf dem
prüfstand reduzierte 9 millionen
angeblich umweltfreundliche diesel waren
tatsächlich stickoxid schleudern
volkswagen fühlt sich heute selbst
hintergangen aber was wusste ex
vorstandschef martin winterkorn damals
schon über den betrug winterkorn war
einmal deutschlands vorzeige manager
heute sollte auch der prozess gegen ihn
beginnen wegen krankheit des 74 jährigen
wurde das verfahren aber abgetrennt und
verschoben winterkorns verteidigung bank
auf zeit spielen der prozess gegen ihn
wird kaum vor 2023 beginnen winterkorn
vor gericht wäre das wichtige zeichen
dass auch große bosse nicht über recht
und gesetz stehen
130 prozesstage für die aufarbeitung des
bisher größten wirtschafts betruges in
der bundesdeutschen geschichte
die sichtbar gewordene spitze eines
eisbergs so sehen es ermittler und
demonstrierenden vw-mitarbeitern draußen
vor dem verhandlungssaal in braunschweig
sind eine handvoll angeklagte noch nicht
genug
nach sachsen-anhalt da ist
ministerpräsident reiner haseloff von
der cdu mit einem dämpfer in seine
dritte amtszeit gestartet im ersten
wahlgang verpasste haseloff überraschend
die mehrheit im magdeburger landtag im
zweiten anlauf klappte es dann auch wenn
ihm da erneut mindestens drei
abgeordnete seiner neuen koalition aus
cdu spd und fdp die unterstützung
verweigerten die landtagswahl im juni
hatte die cdu deutlich gewonnen
zu kronach da sinken die zahlen leicht
doch die bundesländer wappnen sich
bereits für herbst und winter allerdings
vollziehen sie den spagat zwischen
freiheit und gesundheitsschutz
unterschiedlich jedes land mit eigenen
regeln viele setzen auf zweig heißt mehr
freiheiten in läden oder restaurants die
nur geimpfte und genesene reinlassen und
es gibt unterschiedliche alarmstufen
grundlage hierfür ist vor allem die lage
in den krankenhäusern wie das seit heute
in baden württemberg aussieht berichtet
sven klasse mal wieder eine neue corona
verordnung durcharbeiten dem
fitnessstudio von michael städte sie
sieht weitreichende beschränkungen für
menschen vor die weder geimpft noch
genießen sind rund 20 prozent der
mitglieder sind das hier primär das
jüngere publikum
und das wäre schlimm wenn diejenigen
dann nicht mehr zum trainieren kommen
können wer nicht geimpft oder genießen
ist kann hier bisher mit einem negativen
schnelltests trainieren steigt die zahl
der kobe patienten in den krankenhäusern
aber ginge das in einer ersten stufe nur
noch mit negativen pcr test eine zweite
stufe wird ausgelöst wenn die sieben
tage hospitalisierung since it ends bei
12 oder höher liegt oder mindestens 390
intensivbetten mit kobe patienten belegt
sind dann gilt vielerorts 2 geht nicht
geimpfte und nicht genesen würden dann
also von weiten teilen des öffentlichen
lebens ausgeschlossen die neuen
regelungen in baden württemberg strenger
als derzeit anderswo
wir wollen niemanden bestrafen
und das ergibt sich einfach daraus dass
wir auf diese weise ein paar versuchen
die partie im griff zu halten
es gibt ausnahmen bei den regeln etwa
für kinder schüler schwangere und
menschen die nicht geimpft werden können
die debatte dennoch kontrovers finde
grundsätzlich gut
wir sind für alle irgendwie in einem
boot das ist für mich zu hart weil die
ungeimpfte bitte auch am leben teilhaben
dürfen noch liegt die zahl der belegten
intensivbetten unterhalb der
verschärfung stufen modellrechnungen
gehen aber davon aus dass die erste
stufe bereits ende des monats erreicht
werden könnte
3g oder zweig jedes bundesland hält es
da ein bisschen anders wo genau geimpfte
auf weitere vorteile hoffen können das
zeigen wir ihnen in unserer zdf heute
app aber auch wo nur getestete mit
einschränkungen rechnen müssen
von januar 2020 bis mai 21 war der
schulunterricht in deutschland wegen
corona an zwei von drei schultagen
gestört das geht aus einem bericht der
oecd hervor der organisation für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung das bedeutete für rund elf
millionen schülerinnen und schüler und
auch für ihre eltern mehr als 180 tage
homeschooling wechsel unterricht oder
anderes weil schulen nicht oder nur zum
teil geöffnet waren deutschland die
damit international im mittelfeld und
noch eine studie zu corona von den
vereinten nationen
danach gibt es keine anzeichen dass die
welt nach corona klimafreundlicher wird
der rückgang der kohlendioxid emissionen
durch die lok downs sei nur ein kurzer
aussetzer gewesen der klimawandel
beschleunige sich weiter im ersten
halbjahr 21 stießen fabriken und
kraftwerke wieder mindestens so viel co2
aus wie vor der pandemie die welt sei
noch immer weit vom plan entfernt die
ziele des pariser abkommen zu erreichen
so un-generalsekretär gute risch der
klimawandel macht naturkatastrophen
wahrscheinlicher sowie in
rheinland-pfalz und nordrhein-westfalen
vor zwei monaten als in kurzer zeit so
viel regen viel wie noch nie
das hochwasser zerstörte ganze
straßenzüge riss menschen in den tod
viele standen vor dem nichts doch auch
die hilfsbereitschaft war und ist
riesengroß mindestens 510 millionen euro
wurden laut dem deutschen
zentralinstitut für soziale fragen
bisher gespendet die gerecht zu
verteilen ist allerdings kompliziert und
viele betroffene warten dringend auf
geld dominic miller usa
vom fachwerkhaus von familie spalek
stieg im erdgeschoss nur noch das
gerippe eigentlich müssten sie nun
dringend loslegen und sanieren kosten
etwa 150 bis 200 tausend euro doch an
spendengeldern über ein bisschen
soforthilfe hinaus ist bei den spar ex
nichts angekommen dabei hatten sie fest
damit gerechnet dass die großen
spendenorganisationen weiterhelfen
würden
ich habe schon bei einigen angerufen ich
nenne jetzt auch keinen namen ich habe
keine hilfe bekommt man kann ja immer
sehen dass wenn man deutschland hilft
oder lichtblicke oder was auch immer an
druck klickt dann kommt man auf eine
seite wir können sie spenden aber da
findet man nirgendwo hier können sie
spenden abrufen
hilfsorganisationen wie die diakonie
gehen von haus zu haus und können zwei
3000 euro soforthilfe direkt auszahlen
doch bei großen summen ist das prozedere
langjähriger erklären sie den
betroffenen immer wieder zunächst muss
geklärt werden ob eine versicherung
einspringt dann muss klar sein wie hoch
die staatlichen hilfen sein werden für
die geschädigten die bald fließen sollen
und dann kommen erst die spendengelder
zum zug ganz zuletzt dass es jetzt der
nächste schritt das eine zusage gemacht
wird wie viel geld gibt es vom staat und
wir dann als diakonie kirche und auch
andere organisationen dann sagen können
die lücke die sich ergibt da springen
wir ein und unterstützen vorrangig
müssen versicherungen und staat zahlen
dann erst dürfen überhaupt spenden
fließen je nachdem wie viel hilfe dann
noch gebraucht wird und dann erst hat
man irgendwie einfach die bedürftigkeit
lage um so ein technokratisches wort
verwenden aussieht bei dem jeweiligen
betroffenen und danach richtet sich dann
im prinzip die höhe wie der betroffene
spendenmittel unterstützt werden kann
alles soll seine richtigkeit haben doch
es muss auch schnell gehen mit den
staatlichen hilfen und spendengeldern
sagen die sperlichs der winter steht vor
der tür
schätzungsweise 33.000 menschen sterben
jedes jahr in der eu weil kein
antibiotikum mehr bei ihnen wirkt der
grund resistente keime die auch in der
massentierhaltung entstehen eine
initiative deshalb fünf antibiotika
gruppen für die behandlung von tieren zu
verbieten ist jetzt im eu parlament
gescheitert in mastbetrieben bekommen
häufig auch gesunde tiere über futter
oder das trinkwasser antibiotika auch
die eu-kommission verfolgt den plan den
einsatz hier einzuschränken
und jetzt fußballs wenn da gab es licht
und schatten bei den deutschen vereinen
in der champions league nur mit dem
schatten an barbara rb leipzig wollte
nach dem schlechten saisonstart in der
bundesliga beim englischen meister
überraschen doch manchester city hatte
immer eine antwort parat am ende steht
eine ernüchternde 3 6 niederlage für rbi
nach noch die muckis eigentor liegt
leipzig 0 2 hinten ein rückstand den
selbst drei tore von christoph von kongo
nicht wett machen weil auch city immer
wieder trifft nach dem konkurs eins zu
zwei nach seinem 2 zu 3 und nach seinem
3 zu 4 stets ist city das velo macht das
5 zu 3
die haben alles oder nichts gespielt
immer nach vorn das gibt natürlich raum
und wer es vor dem tor am besten
hinkriegt der gewinnt nun mal das spiel
vor dem spiel dann waren zu mir sagt ja
du kriegst drei tore dann glaube ich
dass es super aber wir haben zu viele
individuelle fehler gemacht in unterzahl
kassiert leipzig kurz vor schluss das
sechste gegentor durch gabriel jesus
eine lehrstunde für die sachsen in
manchester
beeindruckend dagegen der bvb bei
besiktas istanbul auch den lauten
anfeuerungen der 23.000 gegnerischen
fans im stadion hielten die dortmunder
stand zwei bvb stars ragten heraus
das dortmunder traumduo hatte liefert
die jungen wilden early harland und der
erst 18 jährige gut bellingham
luft drei jahre gültig was soll ich
sagen
und so macht es der engländer mini sieht
ihn und er lässt sich nicht aufhalten
eine perfekte ballannahme und das 1 0 in
der 20 minute auch als vorbereiter
genial in der nachspielzeit der ersten
hälfte legt bellingham auch für holland
der trifft zum 2 0 sein 21 store im
siebzehnten champions league spiele die
defensive des bvb diesmal meist stabil
der anschlusstreffer feld der noch kurz
vor abpfiff und dementsprechend immer
happy dass wir dass wir die drei punkte
in zwei wochen das nächste
champions-league-spiel mit dem traumduo
dann gegen sporting lissabon
alle spiele alle tore gibt's übrigens in
der zdf- heute-
dankeschöns wenn im urlaub alles hinter
sich lassen wer möchte das nicht diesen
vier ist es vergönnt die
weltraumtouristen starteten vergangenen
8 mit einer sex rakete zu einem rundflug
um die erde was der drei tage trip
gekostet hat ist unbekannt ein
schnäppchen war es vermutlich nicht und
vertrauen gehört auch dazu schließlich
steuert kein astronaut sondern nur der
autopilot
hier in unseren gefilden wird es etwas
kühler als in den vergangenen tagen mehr
zum wetter hat gleich aus dem verlies
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute journal
danke für ihr interesse einen schönen
abend noch und bis morgen wenn sie mögen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der regen im süden
deutschlands lässt allmählich nach denn
das tief ihr verlagert sich langsam nach
osten allerdings zapfte es von norden
her kühlere luft an und so gibt es in
der nacht im norden regen und anfangs
der nacht sogar noch einzelne gewitter
ansonsten haben wir es mit vielen wolken
zu tun nach westen hin bildet sich nebel
genauso wie im südwesten und an den
alpen regnet es ebenfalls noch etwas die
temperaturen sinken im westen auf 8 grad
ähnlich auch nach süden bis neun grad 14
grad zum beispiel an der ostsee morgen
im tagesverlauf dann vor allem im
nordosten viele wolken oder es regnet
ansonsten auch über den mittelgebirgen
einzelne schauer aber deutlich
freundlicher nachlässen denn hier gibt
es viel sonnenschein ähnlich auch im
süden hier auch immer wieder sonnige
abschnitte mit höchsten temperaturen von
bis zu 22 grad am niederrhein oder aber
auch am oberrhein richtung rhein main
gebiet 21 grad kühl an der ostsee mit 16
grad ja und die nächsten tage am samstag
nach ost nennen dichter bewölkt mit
regen nach süden und sonniger bis 24
grad ab sonntag nicht mehr ganz so warm
und vor allem im süden regen damit ein
schöner abend